- Welcome, welcome to another Fed Day,
FOMC day edition of "Market Takes."
I know you could have been
anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me
and I appreciate that.
Thank you so much.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the "Wall Street Journal."
This is "Market Takes."
We are diving into today's
FOMC press conference,
the statement, the decision, all that.
We are gonna break down
what all of it means
and explain why it matters.
Today's meeting I think was
a little bit more subdued,
a little bit, you know,
you didn't have a lot of the big fireworks
that we've come to expect from Fed Day.
But, nonetheless, there is
some very important context
and we are gonna get into
right here on "Market Takes."
We're gonna talk about, of
course, the Fed rate decision,
and how that aligned with expectations.
We're gonna talk through
what's going on in the markets,
how markets reacted across stocks, bonds,
currencies, commodities,
all that good stuff.
And, of course, we're gonna talk about
the environment coming into the meeting,
and how today's meeting
and press conference
and all that may have
shifted things going forward.
And then of, course, we will
talk about what comes next
'cause, you know, even though
it's backward looking data,
we are always looking forward.
Anyway. So looking, let's get to it.
The Fed decision today,
the FOMC raised rates by 25 basis points.
This was widely expected,
widely priced in,
not surprising anybody.
The Fed raising rates from 4.75 to 5%
to 5% to 5.25%, effectively 5.1%.
Wanna put a chart up here on your screen
so you can just look for yourself
and see, kind of, the environment
that we have right now.
All the way on your right
you see how high the rates have gotten.
We are back above 5%.
That is the highest the rates have been
since September of 2007.
So, almost 16 full years since
we've had rates this high.
And you see what happened
after rates were that high,
they came back down pretty quick.
We had a recession, as you
see with there, shaded in.
That is not necessarily indicative
of what will happen now,
past results are not
indicative of future results
but we shall see.
It's definitely gonna be interesting.
We are entering the interesting times now,
the times where things
get a little bit harder,
a little more difficult for the Fed,
for Fed chair Jerome Powell.
So, that charge is kind of illustrating
where we are in terms of the Fed rate
and how that compares with recent history,
at least over the past 20 years.
A big thing that I think was
interesting from this report,
and my biggest takeaway
in terms of the statement,
was the change that, instead of saying,
there's some additional firming ready
that that could be done,
the statement now says,
"The Fed is determining the extent
to which some additional policy
firming may be appropriate."
RSM Chief Economist,
Joe Bruce Willis, said,
they were "Opening the
door to a strategic pause
at the June meeting."
Basically that was market's takeaway.
The Fed said that they
were going to, kind of,
reassess, reevaluate, they
were gonna hike today.
But at the press conference,
even Fed chair Jerome Powell said,
"The changes in the
statement were intentional."
They made those changes to say,
look, it's time we kind of step back.
We've been raising rates every meeting.
Ten straight meetings
they've increased rates,
including raising 75 basis points
three times the normal pace
at four meetings earlier this year.
So, some big changes were made
and now we are entering a new phase
of this rate hiking cycle.
And that's what I think you're seeing
the market respond to right now.
Coming into this meeting today,
things have been pretty
straightforward and easy, right?
Now, it's not necessarily
easy to raise rates
because, of course, markets want low rates
but with inflation being high,
it got up to as high as 9% in June.
Of course, the Fed has to raise
rates - it's pretty simple.
Inflation goes up, the Fed has
to respond by raising rates.
They put it off in 2021
saying, transitory, transitory,
we think it's gonna go away on its own.
When that didn't happen
it became clear they had to
raise rates, they did that.
Now we're entering the phase
where it's not gonna be so easy anymore.
You had high inflation, low unemployment,
well in that case you raise rates.
It's very simple.
And the unemployment rate
didn't pick up very much
as they've been raising rates.
What you were starting to see in the data,
and we'll get more into
this in just a second,
is the unemployment data
starting to move in
the opposite direction.
You're seeing job losses start to pick up.
You're seeing inflation
start to come down,
and now the Fed really
has to make a hard choice
or start making some hard
choices in the next few months.
So the Fed was really
setting the table for that
coming into today.
Now we had seen an environment
where stocks had been rising.
You saw the S&P 500 up
around 7% year-to-date,
it had been up almost...
It had reached a pretty
high point recently.
Nasdaq up about 15%
hitting its highest in
September 12th, 2022 on Friday.
Really almost all of this
growth happened in January
but we have seen stocks picking up.
Bond yields on the other side going down.
That for laymans out there means
an easing of financial conditions.
When they say financial conditions easing,
that's what they mean.
Making it easier for
companies to issue stock
because stock prices are high
or to borrow money because
bond yields are low.
That makes it cheaper to borrow.
That's what we're seeing
right now out there
in the economy for big companies.
And we are starting to
move into an environment
where things could be a little tighter,
a little more uncertain as we go forward.
So, want to throw up another
thing on your screen right here
and this is the Fed's balance sheet.
Now, what you've seen over
the past few years is,
you see the balance sheet just pick up
and hit these extreme levels
where we're passing 5 trillion,
6 trillion, 7 trillion, 8 trillion,
getting almost to $9 trillion.
And then we had what was known as QT
sort of start to begin late last year.
And then when this
banking crisis happened,
you see that pickup
there right at the end,
and that was the Fed injecting
another $300 billion into the system,
into the banking system,
to try to stem these outflows
and worries in the banking
sector about collapsing
and the, you know, some
contagion in terms of banks.
A lot of loans made to big banks,
a lot of buying up of bad assets.
But now we are seeing that reverse again
and you're seeing the line
starting to point down.
We're seeing the beginning of QT again,
aka quantitative tightening.
That just illustrates
the way the Fed's balance
sheet has moved long term,
and we are entering a phase now
where the Fed doesn't have
the wind at its back anymore.
You know, instead of putting that,
injecting money into the financial system
as they had been doing,
getting that balance
sheet all the way up there
to near $9 trillion,
we are, in theory at least,
going to be moving down
where they're taking money
out of the financial system
while holding rates high.
And that is gonna weigh on the economy.
So, like I said, the easy part is over.
Now we are moving into the harder part.
I wanna put one more thing
up here on your screen
and it's just some more economic data.
This is the comparison of job openings
versus unemployed people in the US.
And Fed chair Jerome Powell
has mentioned this a
number of times, he said,
"Just today, during his press conference,
there's still 1.6 unemployed people
or 1.6 job openings for
every unemployed person."
So even if we found jobs
for every single person
counted as unemployed in the country,
there would still be
millions of job openings
left over to be unfilled.
Keep in mind, whether
someone is unemployed or not
does not determine whether
they're unemployed.
That doesn't make any sense.
Here's what I mean by that.
Someone could be out of a job
but if they're not
actively looking for a job,
if they are not telling the
Bureau of Labor Statistics
I am out here looking for a
job and I just can't find one.
If they're not checking in
with some sort of
government agency saying,
I'm looking for a job,
they're not unemployed, they
are out of the labor force.
And what we have seen is
a significant increase
in the number of people
out of the labor force
just not being counted.
A lot of those people, working age people,
between 25 and 55,
so-called prime age workers,
they are not unemployed.
They're just out of the labor force
if they're not looking for a job.
So, the number of unemployed people
has been declining pretty significantly
over the past 20 years and we
saw that speed up after COVID.
So again, you're seeing the
number of job openings decline
but there's still a lot
of job openings out there.
A lot of work looking,
or a lot of people looking for workers,
and a lot of work to be done.
This chart illustrating that trend.
But you're seeing a decline
in the number of job openings
and you're seeing that
number of unemployed people
stay pretty steady
because while some people are
coming back into labor force,
other people are getting laid off,
and that's why we see, kind of,
that line not really moving.
So, now let's take a look
at the market right now.
And let's take a look at what we're seeing
from stock prices.
Now look, we've got this overview.
I'm checking out commodities.
I want to take you back to the overview
and let's look at the stock market.
This is the DOW.
You're seeing the DOW
down about 0.8% right now.
Compare that to the NASDAQ
down about half as much.
But you see the same trend, right?
Whether you're looking
at the DOW, the S&P 500,
or the NASDAQ, all three.
This is the DOW.
And you see right around two o'clock
when the Fed releases its statement,
the market picks up.
And then you see the statement come on,
the press conference starts about 2:30,
and then you see things
just really start to unravel
and the sales just pick up
and people are selling outta those Stocks.
I think this is just a
little bit of a buy the room
or sell the news.
Folks expected this
statement to be dovish.
Folks expected the Fed to
raise rates by 25 basis points.
And when I say dovish, what
I mean is the Fed saying,
okay, we think things are gonna be easier.
We are leaning towards keeping rates lower
or pushing rates lower in the future.
The market has priced in
that the Fed is going to start
cutting rates later on today.
And what we're seeing right now
I think illustrates the
expectations from markets,
and from investors,
that the Fed is going to start moving away
from raising rates, moving
towards cutting rates.
We see that with Fed fund futures prices
as we look out across the market.
And we're seeing it with commodity.
I think the big moves that we've seen
over the past couple days,
oil prices are down about 10%
over the last couple days.
You're seeing that
and that was why we started
off with commodities prices,
oil down big, natural gas down big.
Those commodities, which are
very sensitive to the economy
are starting to move lower in
a drastic and significant way.
We aren't seeing it in stock prices yet.
We've seen it in bonds in the bond market
over the past couple weeks,
but we aren't seeing in Stocks just yet.
So, definitely something
to keep your eye on.
I think what we're seeing
right now in commodities
is important and
definitely worth watching.
So, let's talk about the
press conference really quick,
because that was something
I think that, you know,
there weren't a lot of
fireworks, as I said earlier.
There wasn't any big blowout bombshells
from Fed chair Jerome Powell.
He really just kind of laid it out.
We think now is the time to pause.
We're gonna be data dependent,
meaning that depending on
what happens with the data
we will act well, we can
raise rates, we can cut rates,
we can keep rates where they are.
But I think right now
the bias for the Fed,
based on what we heard from the chairman
and what we read in that statement,
that came out around two o'clock,
is that the Fed's bias is to hold pat,
not raise rates, not cut them
but to just hold them here
at this very high level.
The market does not agree.
The market thinks that we are
going to get, potentially,
another increase in July
and then a cut in September,
a cut in November,
and a cut in December,
as the Fed starts to ease up
on those financial conditions again.
Remember, financial conditions were eased
by the Fed pumping money
out into the economy
into the banks,
even though they didn't engage
in any quantitative easing
or cut rates.
When the Fed pushes money
into the banking system
that eases financial conditions,
makes it easier for banks to lend money
to those small businesses,
to do more borrowing and
to get the economy flowing.
Now they're reversing all that,
as we saw with the Fed balance sheet chart
I put up here on your
screen a little earlier.
All of the things the Fed has done
to ease financial conditions
are starting to come off
and that likely is going
to affect market soon
and certainly is going to
affect the real economy.
And, so this today's press
conference, today's statement,
I think really just set in motion,
all right, we are
resetting where things are
and now we are moving into
this new phase of the economy,
of the job market, and
all that good stuff.
But again, it will be all about the data.
The Fed says they're data
dependent, believe them
because if the data comes in surprisingly,
if the data comes in above
expectations, below expectations,
you can expect the Fed to react
and you can expect
markets to react to that.
That takes us to our
next point really well,
which is what comes next?
Well, tomorrow we get the
Challenger Job Cuts report.
That comes out early in the morning.
You're gonna wanna check that out.
That's from private agency
Challenger Grand Christmas.
They track the number of layoffs,
aka job cut announcements, aka job cuts.
That has picked up pretty
significantly as we've started
and moved into this year.
We have seen 400% increase in March
from last year where job cuts were.
And we'll see if layoffs
continue to pick up steam.
That's not great news for the economy.
Then, on Friday, we get the Jobs report,
we will be right here for "Market Takes,"
breaking down what we've seen
and what to make of that job report.
Fed chair Jerome Powell
pointed out during his
press conference today,
there's been an average
of 345,000 jobs added
over the first three months,
the first quarter of this year.
That is a very high
pace, a very fast pace,
and the Fed wants to slow that down.
They want fewer people getting
jobs, they want fewer raises,
they want less wage growth
among the folks in the economy.
I know that sounds strange,
but that's what they want
because they need to slow inflation down.
So, Jobs Friday is gonna be big.
We hope you'll be with us
right here on "Market Takes".
Then next week we've got
our look ahead on Monday.
Again, "Market Takes" baby, don't miss it.
And on Wednesday the other big kahuna
coming out will be CPI,
the Consumer Price Index,
that report is gonna tell us
what's going on with inflation
and all eyes will be on that
as the Fed moves back towards
its data dependent stance.
No more... We can't just say,
okay the Fed's gonna raise this month
because, you know, that's
what they've been doing.
That's all over.
We are moving into a new regime
where a report, like CPI,
the Jobs report, PPI,
any number of reports,
the Economic Cost Index could move the Fed
to raise cut, hold pat,
and you're gonna wanna watch that data
because that's gonna be big.
That's what the Fed is
depending on moving forward.
Anyway, that's gonna wrap it up for us
here on "Market Takes".
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin.
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me.
I hope you'll do it again on Friday
when we come back right here
for another edition of "Market Takes".